hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich
hoffe natürlich jedes soweit gut mir
geht es natürlich auch wie immer ganz
gut muss ich vielleicht direkt am anfang
sagen er ich habe jetzt ein bisschen
überlegt wie ich das am besten mache ich
weiß halt nur also um ehrlich zu sein
jetzt wahrscheinlich auch zum titel
gesehen ihr habt es auch gesehen ich
habe meine eine million abonnenten
verloren
sei es jetzt also ein sicheres sind ja
nur abonnenten ich will deswegen jetzt
gar nicht groß rum holen oder sonst was
aber ich weiß dass es jetzt immer in den
kommentaren stehen wird wenn ich heute
ein neues video hochladen es steht auch
schon viele den kommentaren habe ich
jetzt gesehen
und ja man schaut halt sag ich mal auf
sowas und deswegen wollte ich jetzt
einmal was dazu sagen
damit das halt nicht so ist und ja ich
glaube ich bin auch wirklich der erste
fall ich weiß gar nicht was bestimmt in
deutschland mittlerweile schon 300 dafür
hat kanäle mit über einer millionen
abonnenten wer das dann halt wieder
rückgängig gemacht hat kann man sich
auch mal drüber also nein man kann sich
nicht darüber freuen ich bin auch muss
ich erkläre ich euch gleich sehr traurig
darüber aber gut es ist halt so
eine million abonnenten verloren special
hinein also ich muss wirklich sagen ich
konnte mir jetzt in den letzten 12
monaten denken dass das vielleicht
passieren wird und es macht mich schon
sehr traurig ich glaube das könnte auch
merken um das ding ist halt kann man ich
habe vor eineinhalb jahren ca so die
million follower erreicht und das war
einfach so geil zu der zeit es war immer
mein ziel ich habe damals als ich mit
youtube angefangen habe ja da war das
noch nicht mein ziel weil das so weit
entfernt war und ich hätte mir niemals
vorstellen können dass es irgendwann mal
passiert aber wenn du dann irgendwann
100.000 abonnenten hast dann denkst du
bois stell dir mal vor dass irgendwann
mal eine million wie krass wäre das denn
und ich habe fünf sechs jahre das
durchgezogen ich habe so viele videos
gemacht das hat mir so unfassbar viel
spaß gemacht und irgendwann hatte ich
das denn erreicht und das war einfach
das größte für mich das war dieser das
war das ziel was ich von der zehnten
klasse bis zu meinem anfang vom studium
was ich immer hatte und irgendwann war
es dann halt so weit also das hat mich
so lange begleitet dieses youtube es war
immer quasi mein lebensmittelpunkt und
ist es auch nach wie vor eigentlich das
ist für mich ich könnte noch so viel
geld verdienen aber ich weiß ganz genau
es wird mich viel glücklicher machen
wenn ich youtube videos drehen könnte
die mir spaß machen und wo ich weiß dass
unterhält viele leute die finden das
cool was ich mache weil das einfach
immer das war womit ich groß geworden
bin und was ich im leben brauchte also
ich hätte mir nach ein zwei jahren
youtube gar nicht mehr vorstellen können
wie wäre es wenn du irgendwann einfach
wenn du wenn youtube jetzt weg ist oder
die den kanal herrscht oder klar da
hätte ich neu anfangen können aber
deswegen trifft mich das natürlich auch
sehr hart dass dieses ziel was ich so
lange hatte jetzt gerade quasi erloschen
ist so gesehen ich sehe das aber auch
als neue motivation um vielleicht noch
mal ein bisschen weiter hinten wieder
anzufangen weil ich muss auch ganz
ehrlich sagen ich habe es oft in den
kommentaren gelesen viele leute
schreiben alex die videos sind irgendwie
nicht mehr so cool man kann nicht genau
erkennen was auf was hast du eigentlich
bock verlierst so ein bisschen den roten
faden man sieht auch dass du nicht nicht
mehr so viel spaß daran hast was sich
natürlich sehr mitnimmt aber ich kann
sagen dass ihr damit recht habt oder die
leute jetzt schreiben dass die damit
recht haben es ist einfach so kummer ich
bin so lange dabei das sind schon 67
jahre wo ich das mache und man muss sich
einfach immer neu erfinden sonst brennt
man irgendwann aus dieses jahr war auf
youtube bezogen natürlich nicht optimal
für mich ich habe mich viel auf andere
sachen konzentriert ich habe zwei firmen
gegründet letztes jahr auch schon habe
da viel zeit rein investiert konto neue
sachen kennenlernen auch eine in dieser
branche einfach mal hinter die kamera zu
schauen und das brauchte ich einfach
einfach mal etwas neues kennenzulernen
so und das java bis jetzt für mich super
ist eigentlich super gelaufen bis auf
youtube halt so da meine eigenen youtube
sachen meine eigene youtube kreativität
und das wirklich ich denke da jeden tag
darüber nach weil es mich auch mitnimmt
und und traurig mache dass ich einfach
nicht mehr dieses feuer und diese
kreativität habe wie ich sie früher mal
hatte ja es kommen so oft leute auf mich
zu dir sagen alex ich habe dich früher
so so gerne geschaut was quasi den teil
meiner jugend jetzt hat auch schon so 20
sind die mich damals mit 14 15 geschaut
haben was mich auf der einen seite total
glücklich macht auf den anderen denkt
man dann halt auch immer so ja wieso
habe ich das so ein bisschen jetzt
verkackt im letzten jahr und ja ich das
kann man auch irgendwie ich muss das ja
einfach mal so sagen dass es mich
wirklich selber tagtäglich mitnimmt und
ich da jeden tag daran denke ja und
jetzt sitze ich hier und muss euch das
mal so erzählen und ich kann verstehen
dass
keine neuen leute mehr dazu kommen die
mich irgendwie cool finden und viele
sagen hey da geht mir auf den sack ich
hoffe nicht dass es ist auch schwierig
geworden youtube macht so leuten die
lange schon dabei sind die auch eine
gewisse reichweite haben mir wird das
leben manchmal echt schwer gemacht
selbst wenn ich mal ein cooles video
habe meiner meinung nach wird es gar
nicht mehr irgendwie vorgeschlagen vom
algorithmus auch mal für neue leute aber
gut so ist das und irgendwie kann man da
sicherlich herauskommen und ich will da
auch rauskommen ich will jetzt weiterhin
coole sachen machen ich habe ein paar
sachen im kopf die hoffentlich
wieder unterhaltsamer sind und so wo man
auch merkt man vielleicht mehr
persönlichkeit von mir merck und ihr
euch einfach mehr spaß beim anschauen
machen ich will aber noch mal sagen
dieses ganze social media game so wie
ich damals gestartet bin ich habe
angefangen wegen dem spaß weil ich bock
hatte youtube videos zu tun ich wurde
jahrelang von vielen leuten deswegen
ausgelacht oder ich habe in meinem leben
bestimmt 5000 sprich es ist kein scherz
5000 sprüche von irgendwem gehört denn
um das so ein bisschen auf die schippe
zu nehmen und am ende konnte ich
jahrelang oder verdiene ich jetzt damit
geld was mir spaß macht ist es mein
hobby auch hinter der kamera und so
weiter und es macht mir so viel laune
das ist ein super positiver aspekt
trotzdem dieses ganze social media game
es ist einfach es ist einfach so ich
wurde mit so vielen ekligen sachen
konfrontiert auch viele viele menschen
da denkst du alter es geht nur um
fucking follower wer hat vor allem auch
jetzt durch tik tok leute oder kinder in
der fünften sechsten klasse vergleichen
sich wert wie viel voller war welches
sektor etwas für eine reichweite
generiert da wird über nichts anderes
mehr gerät auf dem schulhof was komplett
krank ist und es duftet alles so in eine
falsche richtung ab es gibt so viele
menschen dieser branche die leben für
ihre follower war wie viele leute das
vollen und fragen der navy für services
sowie viele users tut für mich gibt es
nichts unangenehmeres als wenn influenza
über sowas reden am tisch also ich hab
da so viel scheiße erlebt in der zeit
ist es ich bin mittlerweile 24 ich
konnte mich dadurch extrem entwickeln
und ich habe super viel erfahrung
gesammelt ich habe da kann ich könnte
stundenlang erzählen über negative
sachen die ich in dieser zeit erlebt
habe aber aus denen man auch gelernt hat
trotzdem ist für mich das wichtigste das
ich auf youtube spaß hat meinen content
zu produzieren und hauptsache es gibt
ein paar leute die das feiern scheiß
drauf dass ich jetzt keine millionen
abonnenten mehr ab dann sind es halt nur
noch ein paar hunderttausend ist auch
geil ja das hätte ich mir auch damals
niemals ausmalen können und ich versuche
einfach wieder so zum alten spaß
zurückzufinden ich hoffe ihr helft mir
dabei vielleicht auch ein bisschen ich
bin mal gespannt auf eure kommentare
hier schreibt gern wenn ihr mir
irgendwas zu sagen habe schreibt ein
dickes dank an alle die mich schon so
lange supporten vielleicht jetzt in
letzter zeit nicht mehr so viel wie
früher aber das kommt wieder ich hoffe
ich denke immer positiv und
danke fürs zuschauen haut rein schönes
wochenende euch noch ach so ja und den
muss ich dann als leider erst mal
abhängen oder
seid mir nichts anderes übrig